are you gonna join me or what
no okay hi guys my name is Tamra
chambers and this is Tamra's never seen
I put up a poll on my Twitter asking if
you guys wanted to see Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure or Robocop
it was super close but Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure won out which I was
silently hoping for because I'm hyped up
on Keanu Reeves after John wick Keanu
Reeves and Alex winter star in this
outrageous comedy about two ditzy dudes
from San Dimas California dizzy is
usually word reserved for girls and I
love love that they use it with these
guys
I assume I already know exactly how
these boys are gonna act and sound just
from the description and then being
placed in San Dimas so without further
ado Thank You Twitter let's go Panama's
never seen party on dudes it's gonna
vary like Wayne's World feel I really
love you guys together so dumb young
Keanu Reeves you're fine but your sinful
movie had a lot of really funny parts
and then there was some weird like
pacing things like I feel like they
spent way too little time in the actual
time zone so they their third time
traveling but they barely spent any time
in these other places like they go to
France to see Napoleon and they pop in
with Rufus and they're like alright here
it is go back no time at all is said and
so I feel like there's all these
costumes and all these extras working in
this like time period and I don't know
it seems like a waste of money I face it
seems like they've been spent very much
time there it seemed the story was kind
of weird like they have this awesome
first half of like going to get these
people and then it was just kind of like
trying to stall for time until they
could go up and give the presentation
there was like the whole chore scene and
then there's like the whole police
station scene the whole mall scene there
was just a lot of time that was like why
are they doing these things why don't
they just go to the
school I don't know I guess you don't
wanna bring Genghis Khan to your school
functions that being said though super
fun super funny they were hilarious
together counter reason what's his name
Alex winter super cute that they're
trying to start a badge that they don't
know how to play sexy it's like every
person's dream to start a band but I
mean putting the hours in the whole
other thing
take it from me I currently know four
songs on the ukulele
I wrote oh my god bill stepmom was a
senior when they were freshmen that's la
get it girl
I know No so the whole story is kind of
ridiculous and really funny but super
ridiculous
if they fail this whole world if they
retell this oral history exam they're
gonna flunk out of school and then that
is gonna have to go to military school
and so instead of just studying and
creating something a presentation Rufus
George Carlin who comes from the future
where they have influenced them to such
a degree that now they are watching them
in the past he helps them out gives them
a time machine and they go clicked
figures from history which doesn't make
any sense
because at the end they go through their
whole like oral history exam and they're
up there and they're saying ridiculous
things and they're not even saying in
historical facts and like even if Rahim
leaked into substance and he doesn't
even say anything historical because
party on dude they still in real life
even if this Whippany suspend your
belief for a second and this was real
they still wouldn't get an a on this
exam because they didn't actually learn
anything ah kids I wrote for some reason
future but still really ATZ George
Carlin goes to help them out he lands
his program of the circle-k then they
see their future self a 69 dude it's so
bodacious this film came out in 80
887 around there and the graphics are
hilarious like when they're
time-traveling and when they go to the
Future where George Carlin is from so
this is a graphic to get them there are
really funny and super like me new
Americans like 80s so cheesy but somehow
perfect and somehow still is like that
holds up think of the whole tone of the
movies just that so it I like that a lot
so they get Napoleon they get Billy the
Kid they get so crap cheese or so
crazies or whatever they call them
sausages they go to get somebody in the
Renaissance time and then they just see
the historical babes the princesses that
we fall in love with it when they're in
the Renaissance time there's this one
moment where they hug each other because
they think that Ted dies and he doesn't
die and not explained very well but he
doesn't and and so they hug each other
and they both heal at each other and
it was just like okay well the product
of its time sure is an 80s movie right
there I have to say even over like the
graphics that I was just talking about
that
dates it way more that like that was
used like that I don't know you know
what I mean does that make sense then
they go to the future where George
Carlin is from and and everyone is like
super into them and it's like
worshipping them and they're like err
strumming their air guitars and it like
I laughed out loud it's just ridiculous
then they go and they just get a bunch
of people so you get Jonah bars when you
get Beethoven and you get Genghis Khan
Lincoln and it's just this whole montage
of collecting historical spirits and
again I wish this wasn't a montage as
much as it was like specifically going
to these people's places and like
talking to them about what they did but
while all this is happening I really
enjoy the part that they've left and
Napoleon instead younger brother and
he's eating ice cream and he's bowling
and he's just having the time of his
life
and then like what we'd have to go find
him now where'd he go of course is the
water park of Waterloo I'm like I know
Napoleon did some really bad things but
I am
right now I wrote his bathing-suit is
amazing
we're gonna get there and there is a
long scene in the mall where Beethoven
is like playing piano and then Billy the
Kid Socrates are like hitting on girls
and Lincoln is getting his portrait
taken and then like punching out a guy
Genghis Khan goes and gets another bat
and somehow learned how to skateboard
and no time at all it's really good pick
it up thanke gangee Annan Joan of Arc is
teaching an aerobics class this is a
long sheet and there were kind of
moments of fun in there but also it's
just kind of like what why is this
happening right now what is this why did
I go to the ball were they stalling for
time did I miss I don't know why is
there a reason they're at the mall also
they're missing school and they're in
danger of failing school that would get
them in so much trouble
so just Sophie I know this movie doesn't
call for a lot of logic though but all
that happens and they get today all the
Bigga all get arrested by Ted's father
who is a policeman and then Ted and Bill
Bill and Ted continue their excellent
adventure break them free with the whole
key scene which is great at this point
they kind of play with time travel more
than they had before which was fun
because they're like alright well we'll
have to remember that in the future
we'll go and we'll leave the keys for
ourselves and then Oh remember to do a
voice thing and remember to Jack and
remember to do the trash can over the
add set so all of those were fun was the
kind of the first time that they did
that kind of play with it which I
enjoyed they're so ridiculous so putting
them in a situation where they're doing
something like time travel it's just so
dumb stupid and it's super fun for the
history report like I was saying earlier
like it's so ridiculous they haven't
shown that they've learned anything I
don't think they would get an A for this
also they're criminals because they
broke out all the C's people from the
jail so I love it it's the specific then
at the end of this report
thank sucking travel out of the school
and everyone's in the auditorium and
they're just like yeah they go crazy but
no questions are asked they time travel
in front of the teachers and the
policemen and the parents and all of the
students and nobody asks any questions
they're like what a cool report a class
man and then Rufus shows up with the
babes from the Renaissance area the
historical babe he's like they're in
your band too and then gives them two
wonderful guitars it's like all right
happy ending there we go
he also explains that their music is the
end to war and poverty in the future it
aligns planets and harmony and I'm just
like oh right well why not if it makes
any sense at all George Carlin picks up
a guitar and he starts shredding and
just did you I just learned he didn't
actually he didn't actually play the
guitar stuff all right
good finger placement sir very tricky
George definitely moments associated
that's my fault for seeing this in 2017
versus when I was young it was supposed
that's a part of this series for me is
is that even if I really enjoy the film
I still realized that it was been way
better if I would have seen this as a
kid or even like in college if I would
have seen this with friends and drank
beer like I did you know what I mean it
would have been more fun than on like
noon on a Monday with my cat I know a
lot of people have a very deep
connection to this bill and I could see
why I'm glad to have seen it but I
definitely didn't she I am excited to
see Robocop I assume it's a robot that's
a cop the my educated guess there Walter
kind of introduced this new thing in the
rocky cameras never seen where he wrote
down some predictions and and then as we
went through he kind of like revealed
them to me and I would love to do
something like that maybe when I filmed
the Robocop review before I start
filming it I will tweet something and
then the responses that I get during the
filming process
I'll then like look at and then like
reveal after I'm done filming baby maybe
that'll work cuz I won't see them before
hands that could be fun and then kind of
get people involved in it too basically
everyone can just say it's not what you
expected and she liked it anyways thank
you for watching everyone
I suppose to you next week and I'll get
your predictions on Twitter
[Music]